mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
zu einem video wo ich euch etwas tolles
sage nach 20.000 jahren die wir uns
jetzt mit dem support unterhalten dann
haben sie mir diesen account die
zurückgegeben das bin ich das ist dass
es kaum kraft
mein gott was ist das hier ich spiele
mittlerweile tatsächlich so selten
minecraft dass ich dass ich alles auf
einmal so schätze was ist das ich habe
mich 1000 jahre mit dem support
unterhalten und auch über mein netzwerk
und danke an alle personen die da
involviert waren das waren elia und jen
und ganz viele leute die ganz oben bei
studien 70 sitzen und auch mehrere leute
bei microsoft und leute beim ausgang und
an euch danke irgendwie haben die jetzt
festgestellt dass tatsächlich der
wirkliche inhaber von diesem account bin
und die 15.000 euro die mir die person
die ich hier vorgestellt und geboten
haben damit er mein account zurückholten
kann ich jetzt ablehnen ich habe meinen
account zurück kann deswegen nun wieder
auf ganz normalen servern spielen und
dort ganz normal irgendwie keine ahnung
minigames und ihr könnt mich jetzt
wieder auf servern sehen und so weiter
und so vor
du wurdest permanent vom server netzwerk
gebannt grund sicherheitspannen
ach ich habe komme ja gesagt er soll
mich banden die kennen mich ja jetzt
wieder ich bin das schon so als diese
andere kordic hatte ich bin profi
bildschirm gewohnt dass da keiner mehr
umstand aber jetzt ist ja wieder hier
wieder mal wieder was angesagt hier
beispiel jetzt einfach mal eine runde
dauern weil ich das tatsächlich so sehr
liebe bin ich eigentlich bin sogar
youtube mensch iran nicht wie geil das
ist dass ich jetzt wieder ganz normal
minecraft spielen kann man meinen stil
stellen kann get down geht los und das
ist jetzt quasi nur so dass ich euch mal
kurz zeige den dauert natürlich [ __ ] you
dance mal platz 90 kurs ist es gut das
video hier ist nur dazu da dass ich mal
kurz sage ja tag ich habe meinen account
bekommen jetzt wieder wie die neu wie
könnte das überleben und ich habe lucky
ich hatte lucky ich hatte da so die kag
probleme mit treckern und die ganzen
vorfeld ich hatte das ja nicht nur bei
minecraft hier sondern
beim einem twitter-account sei es mir da
nicht folgt das wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mehr warum warst box dir denn alle ich
hatte ja nicht nur bei meinem minecraft
kaum probleme sondern auch bei twitter
und da wurde ich auch gehackt und das
war dort viel schlimmer weil ich auf
twitter jeden tag aktiv bin und in
minecraft nur einmal die woche halten er
ist das traurig jetzt zwei kreft nämlich
halt nur einmal die woche was auf und
twitter hat mich halt viel mehr so in
meiner person eingeschränkt er verfolgt
mich ziemlich locker runter prügeln
das habe ich jetzt allerdings alles
zurückbekommen twitter support balls ich
bin ich bin der tod ist es das ist wahr
ich liebe das hier ich grüße markus
lukas und die 7a markus und lukas und
die komplette 7a schöne grüße an dieser
stelle von ruben amorim ich sehe schon
kommen der läuft jetzt morgen ging wie
eine schule und alle sagt morgen ist
samstag
ich bin am vorproduzieren tut mir leid
für mich korrekt noch mittwoch aber ich
sehe schon gut läuft in die schule und
alle sagen worüber weil wahrscheinlich
auch jeder von der schule meinen videos
wo bin ich hier es ist so viel platz in
dieser map und ich steh komplett am rand
was ist es jetzt wieder grüßt hier jeder
von crafter hat den skill zu hause
gelassen kontrast eis matsch dass
spieler zu begriffe nachkommen
allerdings map in der regenbogen map
hier gerade das ist ja alles so
wundervoll
das will ich aber nicht spielen weil ich
jetzt schon weiß dass youtube deswegen
die qualität runter wird regeln wird das
ist einfach so weil das so viele
verschiedene farben sind und dann wird
das komplette bild auf einmal schlecht
das heißt wenn das billett schlechtes
liegt an der map die wir gerade gezockt
haben also zusammenfassen zu diesem
video jetzt immer zu sagen ich habe
meine kann zurück das heißt wenn ihr ich
bin profi ingo sie dann ist es deswegen
weil sich irgendeiner den account dann
geschnappt hat der da der wird ihr dann
auch einem
also wieder verfügbar sein das ist mir
relativ egal was du wichtig dass jetzt
konnten wieder habe das haben wir jetzt
auch hingekriegt und ich habe den
account zurück ich bin total froh dass
ihr euch so involviert habt ihr diese
ganze sache und auch mojang geschrieben
habt und vanessa und auch noch mal
tanken denn ilja studio 1 70 microsoft
mojo die da sich darum gekümmert haben
an dieser stelle bin ich auch das video
ich wollte eigentlich viel kürzer halten
und nur kurz ich hab mein account zurück
hallo an alle server ihr könnt mich
wieder von der en blanc christoph nestor
unternehmen und auch kommen du darfst es
auch machen danke und wir sehen uns
irgendwann wieder randvoll meine fans
keine schlachten